[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video i'm going to be discussing
hogwarts the finest school of witchcraft
and wizardry
in the wizarding world more specifically
i'm going to be discussing something
that you've probably never thought about
the school's plumbing system
hogwarts was founded around 990 a.d when
four 10th century witches and wizards
got together
and decided that they had in the sorting
hats own words
the self-same yearning to make the
world's best magic school
these founders were godric gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw
salazar slytherin and helga hufflepuff
when the quartet finally got together
they put their magical powers together
and hogwarts was born
when hogwarts was first founded it was a
time of hardship for witches and wizards
as everyday magical folk were being
persecuted by muggles
for their abilities it was a time of
tension and hostility
which is why it was so important that
the magical school remained hidden
somewhere in the scottish highlands
students began attending the school
right away
and the four founders each helmed one of
the four hogwarts houses
gryffindor southern ravenclaw and
hufflepuff
this time period differed from the
current time period in many ways
and the hogwarts castle was no exception
to changes
through the passage of time over the
years as technology progressed
the castle was outfitted with upgrades
as to reflect these new technologies
and one supremely important piece of
technology that we didn't always have
around
that is often overlooked is the toilet
according to wikipedia
the first modern flushable toilet was
described in 1596
by sir john harrington an english
courtier and the godson of queen
elizabeth the first
harrington's device called for a two
foot deep oval bowl
waterproofed with pitch resin and wax
and fed by water from an upstairs
cistern this meant that for hundreds of
years the hogwarts castle had no toilets
in fact according to jk rowling hogwarts
wasn't outfitted with proper toilets
until the 18th century so what you might
ask
did witches and wizards do to relieve
themselves before the introduction of
toilets into the castle
well this peculiar 2019 tweet from the
wizarding world twitter
gives us some insight hogwarts didn't
always have bathrooms
before adopting muggle plumbing methods
in the 18th century witches and wizards
simply relieved themselves
wherever they stood and vanished the
evidence now while this sounds absurd
and disgusting
relieving themselves where they stood
was actually a much less animalistic
method than what the rest of the world
was doing before the introduction of
toilets in fact before the modern day
toilet became commonplace
muggles would use chamber pots large
basins located
inside of the house however there was no
plumbing to speak of
that was attached to these chamber pots
thus the contents were simply thrown out
of the window
or off the balcony if people needed to
relieve themselves
and they were out and about it was
common practice to simply drop trowel
and do the business right where you
stand in fact this practice was so
common that in a 1609 book that advised
gentlemen on manners
there was a whole segment on how to deal
with the smell of other people's
excrement
in the mid 1700s hogwarts finally
installed its plumbing system
and interestingly enough this plumbing
system actually endangered
the hidden location of hogwarts founder
salazar slytherin's
chamber of secrets the same chamber
containing the fabled basilisk
intended to rid the school of
muggleborns this is because the proposed
plumbing system was constructed
right on top of it according to canon a
descendant of southern who's at the
school at time
helped to keep the chamber hidden by
concealing the trapdoor that led to the
chamber
i love that that's canon but the canon
that i love even more
in such an absurd way is that witches
and wizards simply did the business
vanish the evidence what a concept
however this notion also brings with it
some other questions
what did less talented witches and
wizards do let's say you relieve
yourself
but you're a first year you haven't
quite gotten the hang of magic yet
what then is it the responsibility of
your professor and classmates to dispose
of your excrement
or is the onus on you to do it perhaps
the embarrassment of not being able to
do it
pushes them to learn faster one thing is
for sure which
wizard or muggle people were gross back
in the day
did you guys know this valuable piece of
wizarding canon let me know in the
comment section
below until next time it does not do to
dwell on dreams
and forget to live
[Music]